[Musik]
der russische Angriffskrieg in der
Ukraine hat viele Dinge deutlich gemacht
eines davon ist die enorme Überlegenheit
der US-amerikanischen Militärtechnik
dank des amerikanischen Equipments ist
es gelungen die russische Armee in die
Schranken zu weisen dabei galt diese vor
dem Angriff noch als eine der größten
und vermeintlich stärksten Armen der
Welt um nur ein Beispiel zu nennen nur
20 heimats waren in der Lage den
russischen Invasoren empfindliche
Schläge zu verpassen und die Russen in
die Flucht zu schlagen wohlgemerkt 20
Stück die USA haben daheim über 400
davon oder die jeweiligen an die Panzer
Rakete sie wurde schon am Anfang des
Krieges zum Albtraum der russischen
Panzerfahrer mit anderen Worten die USA
haben genug Waffen geliefert damit sich
die Ukraine effektiv verteidigen können
und vielleicht sogar den Krieg gewinnen
[Musik]
allerdings sind diese Lieferungen nichts
im Vergleich zu dem Arsenal dass die USA
noch für sich zur Verfügung haben
allein die Luftwaffe mit B1 und B2
Bomben die F22 tankkappenjäger die F35
Kampfjets über die wir mal ein Video
gemacht haben America rules the skies
und das ist keine Übertreibung und es
regiert auch die Meere mit modernsten
jagdubuten der Virginia und der Wolf
Klasse Amerika kann mit seinem
Flugzeugträgern wie etwa der Null
mächtigen Ford krasse überall auf der
Welt militärisch angreifen
präzisionskörper wie die Tomahawk
treffen Ziele mit wenigen Metern
Streuung in 1600 km Reichweite die
U-Boote der Ohio Klasse bilden eine
mächtige Säule der atomaren US
Abschreckung die 400 heimats haben wir
schon erwähnt die US Armee dominiert die
Schlachtfelder aber auch Mitchi
Kampfhubschraubern und ihren Adams
Panzer hinzukommen in allen
Teilzeitkräften modernster Raketen
sensuren aufklärungs- und
logistiktechnik die Liste ist hier
unendlich sie umfasst nicht nur die
genannten spektakulären Waffensystem
also es ist Hightech im Großen wie im
Kleinen die Qualitätsunterschiede
zwischen us-ausrüstung und Russen
Technik sind gewaltig Weltkrieg eben
gezeigt hat es ist als würde man einen
brandneuen Ford F150 Raptor mit einem
Lada Niva vergleichen kurz gesagt die
russischen Streitkräfte sind keine
ebenbürtiger Gegner des US-Militärs es
ist eher so als hätte man die Waffen bei
Wisch bestellt das weiß man mittlerweile
auch im Pentagon in der neuen nationalen
Sicherheitsstrategie der beiden
Regierung wird China als potenzieller
Rivale genannt nicht Russland und sie
bezeichnen China nur als potentiellen
rival weil andere sind Militär die
Chinesen eben noch immer weit voraus ist
aber so spektakulär und gewaltig das US
Militär wirkt es gibt doch einen kleinen
Kratzer im Block und diese ist ebenfalls
durch den Ukraine Krieg sichtbar
geworden
Anfang 2022 veröffentlichte das Pentagon
einen Bericht und warnte vor einer
Schwachstelle seiner Streitkräfte und
diese Schwachstelle hatte nichts mit
einem bestimmten Jagdbomber einer
Fregatte oder einer Rakete zu tun es
handelt sich viel mehr um eine Art
ökonomische Achillesferse sie hat mit
der Struktur des militärischen
industriellen Komplexes der USA selbst
zu tun worum handelt es sich bei diesen
Komplex und wir sprechen hier von der
wichtigsten fortschrittlichsten und
größten militärischen Produktionsanlage
der Welt diese Industrie stellt alles
her was man sich in Sachen Abschreckung
Aufklärung Kriegsführung vorstellen kann
von Intercontinental Raketen Satelliten
und jagdbomben bei der fünften
Generation bis hin zu Funkgeräten
Batterien und Schutzwesten der
militärische industrielle komplex ist
eine zentrale Säule der amerikanischen
Weltmacht aber laut das erwähnten
patagon Bericht kam es in dieser
Industrie seit einigen Jahren zu
Veränderungen und die könnten die
nationale Sicherheit der USA gefährden
und worum es dabei genau geht erklären
für euch in diesem Video passt also gut
auf bevor wir loslegen möchte ich euch
aber noch eine kleine Empfehlung für
einen ganz frischen Kanal mit auf den
Weg geben der ebenfalls von unserem
Produktionsteam herausgegeben wird cold
fusion.de
er wird euch bestimmt gefallen falls
euch spannende Stories über Technik und
Wissenschaft aber auch über Gesellschaft
und Politik interessieren wenn ihr zum
Beispiel wissen wollt wieso immer mehr
Menschen Smartphones ablehnen oder warum
der facebook-konzern Meta in Bach runter
geht auf confusion.de erfahrt ihr alle
Hintergründe und Zusammenhänge entdeckt
wirklich ein breites Spektrum
wissenswerter Themen ab ich lasse euch
den Link auf confusion.de in der
Beschreibung unter diesem Video also
schaut mal rein und nun ab nach Amerika
wo wir die große Schwachstelle des
militärischen industriellenkomplexes
unter die Lupe nehmen werden
eine Industrie der Giganten
ohne den militärischen industriellen
komplex wie in Präsident
eisenhowernannte hätten die USA heute
nicht die modernste und schlagkräftigste
Truppe der Welt jeden Tag rund um die
Uhr arbeiten private Auftragnehmer daran
die modernsten Waffen zu entwickeln und
zu produzieren und aus dem Militär zu
verkaufen es handelt sich um einen
Sektor dass er den Jahren eisenhaus kaum
aufgehört dazu wachsen und noch immer
wächst vor allem angesichts derzeitigen
Weltlage jedoch macht sich ein
ökonomisches Phänomen in der
amerikanischen Rüstungsbranche breit und
es treibt den Strategen im Pentagon die
Sorgenfalten auf die Stirn es geht um
einen gigantischen
Konzentrationsprozess Konzentration ist
nicht ungewöhnlich ist das gibt es
überall in der Wirtschaft ein Beispiel
von vielen kleinen Verlagen blieben nach
einer gewissen Zeit nur wenige große
übrig so etwas voll zog sich seit vielen
Jahrzehnten in der deutschen
Verlagswirtschaft und in vielen anderen
Branchen auch die großen schlucken die
kleine sagt der volksuntersuchung ganz
treffen und die amerikanische
Rüstungsbranche bildet da keine Ausnahme
[Musik]
auch dort hat sich die Konzentration in
den vergangenen Jahren extrem verstärkt
und das hat den Wettbewerb verringert
die Folge das Pentagon ist mittlerweile
abhängig von einigen wenigen
industriellen Akteure bei der
Entwicklung von hyperschallwaffen zum
Beispiel hat das Pentagon derzeit nur
einen wichtigen Auftragnehmer
[Musik]
das war früher völlig anders vor 30
Jahren konnte das
Verteidigungsministerium auf 8
Lieferanten von Militärflugzeugen zählen
heute ist noch drei Boeing lockig und
bei Raketen ist die Zahl der Hersteller
ebenfalls von acht auf drei gesunken 90%
der US Raketen werden heute von nur drei
Unternehmen hergestellt Boeing Martin
und Racing bei Militär Satelliten ist
ist das gleiche die Zahl der
Hauptlieferanten hat sich von acht auf
vier reduziert Martin und News und habt
ihr was gemerkt die Namen der Hersteller
haben sich ständig wiederholt das liegt
daran dass ich die Zahl der wirklich
wesentlichen Auftragnehmer seit den 90er
Jahren von 51 auf nur noch fünf
verringert hat ihr könnt sie jetzt auf
dem Bildschirm sehen wie gesagt es
handelt sich um
logitechon Dynamics und Boy noch
deutlicher zeigt sich der Konzentrations
Prozess in diesem Schaubild dass die
Entwicklung der vergangenen Jahrzehnte
darstellt zugegeben es gibt noch weitere
Zulieferer etwa für Komponenten der
großen Waffensysteme aber wenn es um die
großen Rüstungsprojekte geht sind es
mindestens 5 Giganten die sich den Markt
untereinander aufgeteilt und in den
vergangenen Jahren viele kleine
Konkurrenten geschluckt haben es liegt
natürlich auch auf der Hand eine
Supermarkt wie die USA schwebt
militärischen anderen Dimensionen als
der Rest der Welt
ein neuer Flieger oder ein neuer
Flugzeugträger ist da auch immer ein
mega Projekt das überhaupt nur von einem
großen Konzern realisiert werden kann
dass die Kosten in einem solchen Fall
aus dem Ruder laufen sie F35 den 100 ist
aber es sind diese fünf genannten Könige
der Militärindustrie die auch weltweit
unangefochten dominieren ganz gleich
über welche militärische Ausrüstung oder
welche Systeme sprechen einer dieser
fünf Konzerne ist fast immer dabei
natürlich ziehen Sie auch den größten
Nutzen aus dem gewaltigen usb-budget
zusammen haben diese Big Five ein
Börsenwert von mehr als 500 Milliarden
Dollar und machen Einsatz beim erst 200
30 Milliarden Dollar pro Jahr aber so
gewaltig unspektakulär diese Zahlen auch
sind gesund ist diese Entwicklung nicht
und warum und das schauen wir uns jetzt
genauer an
[Musik]
wieder gesehen haben wird durch die
Konzentration die Anzahl der
Marktteilnehmer kleiner das verringert
den Wettbewerb unter Zwang zur
Innovation nimmt ab im Gegenzug steigen
aber die Kosten für den Käufer hier das
US-Militär das macht natürlich sehr
wenige oder keine Konkurrenten auf dem
Markt hat muss nicht übermäßig
Innovation investieren und die Preise
der Produkte senken im Gegenteil man
kann sie sogar noch erhöhen und weniger
Innovation bedeutet weniger Patente
[Musik]
laut Daten der US-Regierung melden
kleine Unternehmen fast 17 mal mehr
Patente an als große Konzern doch in den
letzten 10 Jahren ist die Zahl der
kleinen Unternehmen im militärischen
industriellen Komplex der USA um 40%
gesucht und wenn der
konzentrationssprozess so weitergeht
könnten innerhalb der nächsten 10 Jahre
weitere 15.000 kleine Unternehmen aus
dem Sektor verschwinden das würde die
Innovationskraft natürlich noch viel
weiter reduzieren aber hohe Kosten für
das US Militär als Käufer und mangelnde
Innovationskraft sind nicht die einzigen
Probleme es geht auch Alternativen bei
den Waffensystem das Pentagon könnte
gezwungen sein bei der Entwicklung von
Waffensystemen auf eine der großen
Lieferanten zu setzen schafft diese aber
die Entwicklung nicht zur Einsatzreife
vielen möglicherweise Alternativen oder
noch schlimmer die alternativen stehen
im Ausland durchaus zur Verfügung
vielleicht haben wir eben bei einem
Konkurrenten die China ihr könnt mir
glauben dass die Strategen in Washington
äußerst ungern in solch eine Situation
geraten wollen denn durch
Konzentrationsprozesse in der Wirtschaft
bringen sich auch die Reserve
Kapazitäten damit meine ich
Produktionskapazitäten die durchaus mal
ausgeschöpft werden müssen wenn wie
jetzt im Krieg eine hohe Nachfrage
besteht aber wie kommt dieser Mangel
eigentlich zustande nun wenn ein
Unternehmen ein anderes Unternehmen
kauft oder mit einem Konkurrenten
fusioniert tut ist das fast immer um
Synergien zu erzielen das geschieht zum
Beispiel durch den Abbau von
Überkapazitäten in der Produktion nehmen
wir ein Beispiel stellen wir uns zwei
große Unternehmen vor die jeweils über
fünf Fabriken verfügen zusammen also
über 10
die Fabriken sind in der Lage sagen über
2000 Raketen pro Jahr zu produzieren
also 200 pro Fabrik jedes dieser
Unternehmen verkauft jedoch nur 850
Raketen pro Jahr beide zusammen also
1700 das bedeutet dass sie eine
Überkapazität von 300 Raketen haben wenn
sie jedoch fusionieren könnten Sie eine
der Fabriken schließen und weiterhin
ihre 1.700 Raketen pro Jahr verkaufen es
gibt in diesem Fall war noch eine
Überkapazität aber die beträgt nur noch
100 Raketen pro Jahr das heißt die
reserverkapazität z.B im Fall eines
Krieges ist geschrumpft und das heißt
jetzt nur noch einen statt zwei
Raketenbauer gibt hat sich der
Wettbewerb verringert deswegen kann das
fusionierte Unternehmen wieder dieser
Raketen zu einem höheren Preis verkaufen
der großraketenbauer ist jetzt viel
effizienter und profitabler das freut
zwar die Unternehmen und die Aktionäre
aber wieso eben vorgerechnet geht das
auf Kosten der Reservekapazitäten wie
man den Kriegsfall eben benötigt
und noch ein weiterer Umstand freut
Unternehmen und deren Eigentümer
bereitet aber dem Militärs großes sorgen
Synergien durch die Fusion 2 Unternehmen
zu erzielen bedeutet häufig auch den
Abbau von arbeitslos aber diese
Fachkräfte fehlen dann ebenfalls wenn
man sie im Kriegsfall für erhöhte
Rüstungsproduktion braucht
behalte diesen Zusammenhang bitte im
Hinterkopf dennoch sehen werden wird
dies in den Vereinigten Staaten immer
mehr zu einem Problem aber Moment mal im
Grunde handelt es sich bei diesem
konzentrationsprozessen um längst
bekannte Phänomene aus der Wirtschaft
auch in Washington ist man sich dieses
Problems bewusst und versucht dagegen zu
steuern
[Musik]
in den letzten 10 Jahren hat das
Verteidigungsministerium zum Beispiel
sein Budget zu Unterstützung der
Forschung und Entwicklung in kleinen
Unternehmen in 83% erhöht und seine
Einkäufe bei denselben Zulieferanten 28
%. doch es handelt sich nur um kleine
Schritte denn es hat nicht ausgereicht
um den Verlust von Unternehmen in diesem
Sektor aufzuhalten der
Konzentrationsprozess hat sich sogar
noch beschleunigt
aber warum um alles in der Welt ist
dieser Konzentrationsprozess von
Rüstungsunternehmen der erstatten und
warum ist dessen Tempo in den letzten
Jahren so schwindelerregend schnell und
das hat drei Gründe
[Musik]
erstens gibt es in der Militärindustrie
grundsätzlich mehr Übernahmen und
Fusionen wenn die Militärbudgets
eingefroren oder gekürzt werden der
Grund dahinter ist einfach der Anreiz zu
Energie zu schaffen ist viel größer wenn
der Kuchen plötzlich kleiner ist und
genau das ist in den letzten Jahren
passiert nach dem horrentenausgaben für
Kriege im Irak und in Afghanistan haben
sich die Militärausgaben der USA erst
einmal reduziert und genauso war es in
den 90er Jahren nach dem Ende des ersten
kalten Kriegs machten niedrige Zinssätze
diese Art von Transaktionen immer
einfacher wir haben ja in Folge der
Finanzkrise 2008 viele Jahre niedriger
Leitzinsen hinter uns wenn eine
Rüstungsschmiede in solchen Zeiten Geld
braucht um eine Konkurrenten aufzukaufen
weiß um so einfach an lustige Kredite zu
niedrigen Zinsen zu kommen und das wurde
natürlich nach Strich und Faden
ausgenutzt und drittens hat sowohl die
Komplexität der Beschaffungsprozesse als
auch der Technologie weiter zugenommen
mit Beschaffungsprozessen sind die
Regeln gemeint mit denen ein
Militärapparat sein Equipment beschafft
also Ausschreibungen von Aufträgen
Entwicklung Einkauf und Auslieferung in
den USA gibt es diese in Form der
Federal equisition Regulation ein
Dokument das über 2000 Seiten lang ist
das heißt um eine Ausschreibung zu
gewinnen braucht es eine ganze Stange
Geld für Anwälte und Spezialisten nur um
mit der Verwaltung fertig zu werden wie
komplex und leider auch irrsinnig
bürokratisch das sein kann haben wir mal
in einem Video zur Bundeswehr gezeigt
ich verlinke es euch natürlich denn das
Video hat den Zeiten wie diesen eher
noch an Aktualität und interessant
gewonnen und die wachsende Komplexität
von Regeln und Gesetzen ist praktisch
immer eine versteckte Subvention eine
Bevorzugung der großen Player wenn du
diese Verfügung über das notwendige
Kapital um mit den Bürokratie Monster
die als beschaffungsämter daher kommen
fertig zu werden und ich meine damit
noch nicht mal die beschleunigungsgelder
sondern einfach nur die Ausgaben für
Anwälte und sonstige Regeln verstehen
aber natürlich wollen auch nur geisten
Geld sehen für ihre Tätigkeit und die
großen Waffen schmieden haben auch für
diese Zielgruppe ein paar Dollar mehr in
der Kasse dabei kann es sogar vorkommen
dass große Unternehmen Lobbyarbeit für
mehr staatliche Regulation betreiben
denn auf diese Art drängen sie die
kleinere und lästige Konkurrenz aus dem
Markt aber dieses Phänomen gibt es nicht
nur im Waffengeschäft heutzutage dauert
es Jahre um neue Waffen zu entwickeln
vor allem auch wegen der
beschaffungsregel es bedeutet immer dass
ein Unternehmen gigantischer Ressourcen
investieren und sehr lange Zeit auf die
Erträge warten muss und genau dabei
haben die großen Unternehmen eben einen
großen Vorteil in Friedenszeiten sind
diese ökonomischen Phänomene zwar lästig
aber sie stehen nicht ganz oben auf der
Agenda
der Krieg in der Ukraine hat aber alles
verändert obwohl die USA nicht direkt
beteiligt sind hat dieser Krieg die
Alarmglocken in Washington stillen
lassen und warum genau erklären wir euch
jetzt
[Musik]
wer Krieg offenbart die Schwächen
der Krieg in der Ukraine hat zweierlei
Dinge aufgezeigt wie schon gesagt die
technische Überlegenheit der
us-ausrüstung das ist das eine die
zweite tatsache ist jedoch folgende
washingtonshilfe für die Ukraine hat die
us-bestände als System die stingerboden
luftraketen stark reduziert ebenso die
Zahl der m77 Haubitzen der 155 mm
Munition und von Jeverland Panzer
Abwehrraketen das Problem dabei die
Hersteller dieser schicken Waffen sagen
dass sie Jahre dauernde die verwendeten
Geräte zu ersetzen
die tragbaren Stinger Flugabwehrraketen
zum Beispiel sind enorm wichtig für die
Verteidigung der Ukraine denn sie sind
höchst effektiv gegen russische
Flugzeuge und Hubschrauber schon die
ersten Wochen des Krieges machten sich
zu einem Albtraum für russische Piloten
insgesamt haben die USA mehr als 1.41
ukrainische Militär geliefert vor dem
Krieg jedoch führte der Mangel an
Bestellungen dazu dass die Stinker
Produktionslinien 2005 praktisch
komplett stillgelegt wurden und jetzt
ist es gar nicht so einfach sie wieder
in Gang zu bringen die USA sind zum
Beispiel immer noch nicht in der Lage
eine Bestellung Taiwans aus dem Jahr
2019 auszuliefern
ein anderes Beispiel gefällig Lockheed
market hat gesagt dass es Jahre dauern
wird die aktuelle Produktion von
javelance zu verdoppeln warum nun weil
das Unternehmen nicht genug freie
Kapazitäten hat und es keine
alternativen Anbieter auf dem Markt gibt
[Musik]
genau aus diesem Grund sagt das
US-Verteidigungsministerium jetzt dass
die Vereinigten Staaten Kapazitäten für
die ersatzproduktion ihrer Rüstungsgüter
haben müssen auch wenn das die Kosten
für die Unternehmen erhöht und natürlich
auch für den Steuerzahler man hat er
kann dass man nicht mehr nur Kapazitäten
für die Erhaltung der Waffenarsenal in
Friedenszeiten braucht die Militär
Strategen nicht nur in den USA müssen
jetzt in immensen Ressourcenverbrauch
eines großen abnutzungskrieges mit
einkalkuliert und dabei gibt es ein
Szenario das noch viel schwerwiegender
ist als der Ukraine Krieg ein
chinesischer Angriff auf teilbar
das würde noch viel stärker die
Weltwirtschaft insbesondere Lieferketten
durcheinander bringen und noch mehr
Kriegsmaterial verbrauchen versteht uns
nicht falsch die USA sind nicht
plötzlich wehrlos nur weil sich die
Bestände ans Dingers und chevalance
verringert haben man hat für sich selbst
genug reservenan Hightech Waffen um sich
zu verteidigen oder um den Gegner
abzuschrecken aber trotzdem modernster
Ausrüstung und auch der Fähigkeit
riesige Rüstungsprojekte zu stemmen muss
die Supermarkt Amerika auch die
Fähigkeit haben schnell auf einen
massiven Verbrauchsanstieg zu reagieren
und die Produktion entsprechend
hochzufahren und sei es wie im
wahrscheinlichsten Fall um einem
Verbündeten zu helfen allerdings stößt
man eben durch den rasanten
Konzentrationsprozess in der
amerikanischen Militärindustrie derzeit
angrenzen immerhin hat das
Verteidigungsministerium diese
Schwachstelle selbst erkannt
[Musik]
und derzeit sieht es auch nicht so aus
als ob die Konkurrenz mit ihrer
Militärindustrie viel besser dran wäre
vor allem Russland aber ihr wisst ja wie
ernst die us am militärische
Angelegenheiten nehmen was uns aber auch
immer wieder viel Stoffe unsere Videos
liefert und jetzt interessiert uns eure
Meinung seht ihr auch zu viel Macht und
Einfluss bei dem großen
Rüstungskonzernen der USA können sich
die USA weiterhin als die führende
Supermacht der Erde behaupten ich hoffe
dass euch dieses Video gefallen hat und
ihr vielleicht auch besser gelernt habt
was ja gibt uns bitte ein Like heißt mit
euren Freunden und vergiss nicht das Abo
mit Glöckchen um keines unserer Videos
mehr zu verpassen natürlich freuen uns
auch jederzeit über eine Spende von euch
dieses Projekt weiterzuführen Link dazu
findet ihr in der Beschreibung unter dem
Video macht's gut und bis bald
[Musik]